تمكن رجال الاطفاء في مدينه المحمديه
بالمغرب من السيطره على حريق اندلع في
مخزن الغاز قرب ميناء المدينه
وابعاد ما يمكن ان يتسبب في مشاكل اخرى
واضاف مراسلنا ان اربعه شاحنات لنقل الغاز
على الاقل من اصل سبعه كانت موجوده
قرب شكل كليه
في المناطق السكنيه القريبه من موقع الحدث
على اخلاء منازلهم كاجراء وقائي
من مدينه المحمديه في جنوب الرباط ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره عبد المنعم العمراني
اذا عبد المنعم الوضع لديك الان
تحت السيطره اذا صح هذا التعبير بحسب من
تكلمنا معهم من سكان مدينه المحمديه وايضا
من السلطات المحليه انا اقف هنا في نقطه
حاجز امني يبعد بحولي 200 متر عن موقع
النيران التي اندلعت في حدود الساعه
السابعه مساء بتوقيت المحلي يوم الخميس في
احد خزانات الغاز وبعد ذلك توالت السنه
اللهب في السماء وحدثت عنها انفجارات
كثيره همم ادت الى حاله من الفزع في صفوف
السكان لكن من حسن حظهم ان بحسب ما علمناه
همم تجاوب
الوقايه المدنيه والسلطات كان سريعه
وبالتالي تمكنوا من درع الخطر ومن تفادي
ربما كارثه كانت ستقع في هذه المدينه التي
همم تقع على بعد حوالي 60 كيلومتر جنوب
الرباط وحوالي 20 الى 30 كلم همم
جنوب شمال الدار البيضاء وهي معروفه
بكونها ميناء مختص في المحروقات وبالتالي
هذا التواجد هنا في هذه المنطقه التي تسمى
الجرف الصخري او لافاليز كما يعرفها اهل
المحمديه تواجد عدد كبير من المنشات
الصناعيه وخزانات الوقود وخزانات الغاز
وكل المحروقات
بجولي بانواعها هناك عدد كبير هذه
الخزانات التي احترقت اليوم بها همم
خزانات تابعه لعدد من الشركات المعروفه
همم في توزيع المحروقات وتوزيع الغاز همم
قال لنا ايضا بعض الذين تحدثنا معهم هنا
فان الامر الان تحت السيطره وهم الان همم
يعملون على همم استكمال لتف بتلك الخزانات
وابعاد كل خطر يمكن ان يؤدي الى اشتعال
اللهب من جديد هذا الاشتعال الذي لم تعرف
لحد الان اسبابه لكن السلطات اطلق
التحقيقا في الموضوع لمعرفه ما اذا كان هو
ناتج عن فعل او عن تسرب للغاز من مدينه
المحمديه جنوب الرباط مراسل الجزيره عبد
المنعم العمراني شكرا جزيلا لك